[Music]
you just made this movie Gangster Squad
your co-star Ryan Gosling
here in a couple days you guys are you
guys are pals they are BFFs get is spray
coagulate we are really good friends we
did a move coagulate means to come
together in jello jellies like jello tea
rock down to me good yeah but yeah we
did a half-nelson together which was his
breakout film and i'm happy to say that
i gave him that opportunity so we
decided to work together again on
gangster squad which is short for a
squad of gangsters yes and you guys are
you guys are tight you guys are pals
homeboys he's my you know we have
nicknames I call him my little delicious
vanilla
pedda for hmm in case you're not a
pastry guy like I am it's when you make
a cake you shave it off and make a
little cake and put icing on it and a
little flour and it's very pretty
Ryan Gosling Ryan Gosling to you is a
pretty little cake is a little pretty
white cake well dressed with a little
flower on it do you add you call all
your friends that you name them all
after pastry like you you would be my
little carrot cake dumpling
we don't like carrot cake you like I
would slap you in the mouth you don't
like slap you in the mouth moving a
remote control before the football game
really okay we have a clip here from
Gangster Squad this is man this thing is
packed with action quality film it has
tons of action yes it's a great ride
you're going a tough guy come on come on
easy with the r-word this is a family
show all right I know what you're
getting at there guy come on you see the
suit you're getting excited come on guys
come on come on come on come on
is to microphone you're right yeah mm
everybody say a movies a great rise my
attempt to sleep with a guy get all
willy-nilly in here yeah no chocolate
milk for you saving that for mr. cuoco
she will do well in the hood yes yeah
yeah Big Bang Theory ratings just went
up in Harlem by like 75% you just know
these things
trust me I got an email from the
University of Arizona yes they told me
very nice we have a clip here I don't
even know if this needs explaining this
is just some action from gangsters it's
pretty good and um um I'm in it let's
let's we're gonna look for you in this
class yeah dance is quiet very fast
perfect
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
fun to do it's really fun I love what I
do moviemaking there's nothing like you
cuz you just get to do you get to be the
badass that you can't be in real life
right if I walk up to you and really you
know punch you in the face you're gonna
beat me up no no no no no these are you
know hands of Steel eight okay now we're
David I say it's a great ride and I get
that easy guys it starts massaging your
hand nothing that was quite nice I mean
you know that in time it's absurd
gangster squad